Gabriel fall in Toledo is a two-time
major winner a respected in-game leader
and a devastating hopper and while his
success on counter strikes biggest
stages alone would be enough to mark him
as one of the best players in csgo
history his legacy is built of so much
more than in-game results this is his
story Pauline was born on May 30th 1991
and grew up near Sao Paulo Brazil at a
young age he gained a love of video
games by watching over his brothers
shoulder as he played he was a natural
talent in Counter Strike and by 14 he
was already competing on his first team
Crashers in Brazilian CS 1.6 tournaments
and World Cyber Games events a few years
later he was asked to join fire gamers
whose roster included well-known talents
like Lincoln FNX Lau and Renato and nack
Nakano fallens reputation quickly spread
outside of Brazil
thanks to impressive individual
performances at ESWC and WCG events his
deadly ability with the OP marked him as
the heir apparent to Rafael Kovu Camargo
the best player in Brazil and star of
MIB are what happens is amazingly enough
a player comes up as a rising talent who
basically was as close to Koga as you
could ever get in play style skill set
and even like the role that he used in
the team it was like a koku is toku 2.0
however just as fallen was coming into
his own as a legitimate star level
talent counter-strike in Brazil began to
wane
players became split between 1.6 and the
newer counter-strike source while at the
same time the upper echelon competitors
of the scene such as kagu himself began
to retire or move away from CS but
fallens passion for the game was
unwavering so he began teaching online
counter-strike classes the profits of
which he used to create games academy in
january of 2012 a school dedicated to
teaching high-level counter-strike the
main idea of this project is to give you
guys a good content on how you can
become a better Cisco player and we're
gonna be talking about a lot of stuff a
lot of tips a lot of strategies a lot of
thought you need to understand and how
you can improve your game for the next
few years
fallin continue to grind away a
figurehead around which brazilian
counter-strike rallied but growth was
slow even after the release of global
Offensive in 2012 however once fallen
himself made the switch to csgo
his career quickly regained momentum
after a stint on pro gaming TD fallin
became a founding member of kaboom
eSports his csgo division the roster
which reunited fallen with FNX also
included Fernando fer Alvarenga and the
young guns of Lucas Lucas 1 Telus and
Henry K 10 1 Telus the move would prove
to be a significant stepping stone in
fallens career because it connected him
with fer who has since become his
right-hand man unfortunately for kaboom
their first big international event ESWC
2014 and did not go well their flop + a
merger between kaboom and pro gamers TD
prompted a roster shake-up leading into
fall ins next big test the MLG Aspen
Invitational moment doesn't matter zq
can't still get it it's over just like
that cloud 9 get obliterated against the
Brazilians kaboom I don't think anyone
saw that coming and cloud 9 looks
stunned they look speechless and watch
out world Brazil's got a contender they
look so so so good as a team right
while they didn't make it out of groups
fallens preparation and tactics took
center stage as kaboom TD dismantled
American favorites cloud nine and an
impressive map when the performance
caught the attention of the community
putting fallen back on the map kaboom
followed that up with a solid
quarterfinal finish at clutch Con 2015
their upward trajectory seemed set an
invitation to the ESL one Katowice 2015
qualifiers was fallens reward but there
was just one problem money
kaboom TD couldn't afford to fly the
team to Poland for the qualifier for a
team on the rise
missing the major qualifier would be a
disaster
eh mostly with yet communicate from
starting now McCallister sank regaleira
yeah yeah got a food water here
depression hatred or ice fantastic
because in five days we raise it all the
money we needed while the community
initially came through with around four
thousand euros it was fanatics Robin
flush Ron quest who was the hero
donating a 1400 year old portion of his
share of fanatics first-place winnings
at the iOS pan Tamara to the Brazilians
after an additional twenty five hundred
dollar donation by ESEA kaboom TD was
able to make their way to Poland in time
for the qualifier but successfully
qualifying would mean little if they
didn't perform at the major itself even
with a new sponsor keep stars taking the
financial worries off the teams mind
thankfully the Brazilians once again
showed up in a big way a lot of people
sitting back down steal shotgun head
shot before being dropped in the back
bite test do returns with cracked ember
to pass the third bit to away from the
semi finals had fallen it's gonna have
to make its way through this but this
just no way into that site for them does
connect with his first hit and this
can't ask will go down cqk is waiting to
make his entrance to the site with the
help of fallenness they come in side by
side cqk pushes toward passion for
justice Dartford i am i know that they
were happy with the scar already like
with the quarterfinals but maybe next
year or next event we can see more of
them still well put the keys like they
had a great showing this tournament and
I think they kind of proved everyone
wrong that you know nobody else other
than American and Europe can actually
play well in defense they played really
well and congratulations to them the top
8 finish was enough to earn the team
legend status and a guaranteed spot in
the next major it was a massive weight
off of fallen shoulders and the
culmination of all he had worked for
Brazil which had been quiet since MIB
arse decline was officially back on the
radar wow they had already come so far
it was clear that fallen and his squad
couldn't reach their full capabilities
while based in Brazil and so they signed
with luminosity gaming and moved to
California where they would be able to
train with the best North America had to
offer while also having more chances to
compete in tournaments the decision was
not easy as it meant being away from his
family for an extended period of time
but it was one that had to be made if
fallen was to continue to leave his team
to the top the move to North America
also meant adding star player Marcelo
coldzera David to the mix who under
fallens guidance would blossom into one
of the best players in the world
another top eight finish at the next
major ESL one cologne just a month later
not only proved that the result in
Katowice wasn't just a fluke but that
the move to n8 had been worth it
however he knew there were plenty of
talented players back at home in Brazil
waiting for their opportunity to shine
so in August of 2015
he held a tournament called the golden
chance the winning team he would
personally sponsor under the game's
academy brand and move them to north
america not only with the new team be
able to take full advantage of the na
practice environment fallen and
luminosity would have a new practice
partner just as dedicated and passionate
for the game as they were the winners
were familiar faces FNX hen1 and Lukas 1
along with young talents of epitaxy o
taco de Melo and Gustavo a Showtime can
solve is only a few months into their
time in na luminosity gaming had
improved dramatically but they were
still bumping against the ceiling
presented by European and CIS teams
especially fnatic and non-defense
they're once again a fallen needed to
take a close look at his team and make a
hard choice on November 23rd only a few
days before the face at stage 3 finals
at Dreamhack winter 2015 fallen and
moved FNX and taco from games Academy
into luminosity to replace bolts and
steel
in addition Zeus was brought in as a new
coach in place of neck the move was
sudden and eyebrows were raised as the
Brazilians headed into Dreamhack with
little practice to speak of
they were completely slaughtered in
their first game
[Applause]
sixteen fear of the day perhaps not the
event we were hoping for but fanatic
send a sign across to all the other
things but fallen wasn't going to let a
little obstacle like an O n 16 beat down
a stop him and his team in a now
legendary performance luminosity surged
back into the event defeating ninjas in
pyjamas team solomid ladies and
gentlemen we're gonna see luminosity PD
NV in dramatic best of threes to finish
second at the event behind fnatic Cole
in a one-on-one now of coming from
banana can he smashed the dreams of
luminosity in goes the first set of nice
the force the cold out of this position
there's the peak
something had clicked with the new
luminosity with fallen and Zeus's
tactics first consistency coldzera
superstar power and the dynamic talents
of FNX and Taco LG finally had all the
pieces they needed to take their game to
the next level if I was now luminosity
how all I would like recall from this
tournament is a crazy comeback being
able to pick ourselves up even though
again beaten down the first day one they
played different maps against different
teams had very very decent result they
just changed two players I mean they
should just look forward and just try to
focus on their weaknesses but this is
just something to build on obviously
after second place finishes at Dreamhack
Leipzig and the IEM World Championship
in early 2016
luminosity continued to prove that they
had what it took to make a play for the
next major title fallen was the talk of
the town not only was his tactical mind
and inspiring leadership a clear
catalyst to LG's success but he had
returned to the level of play that had
made him a star in 1.6 his team played
with smarts skills and limitless passion
making them not only incredibly
entertaining to watch but easy to root
for luminosity gaming entered into the
MLG Columbus major in April of 2016
hungry for a title on the site cold
could be going down now everything
riding on taco here they almost signed
up he gets the one spray in turns around
for a second Kevin there it is that
times has gone and luminosity are in the
semies of a major tournament position
but one versus three this is for
everything this is for the map right now
Yuko making its way around the smoke
this family was for Taku but that's it
luminosity where they come back from
1510 and then within very very short
amount of time plays that way this kind
of position seized is gonna be going
down as well for what the follow-up kill
he goes down edward takes two looking
for thirdly calm reloading time he's not
gonna get the killed fallen will be
going down and now it is a one or two
taco look at a sea figure close it out
here and win it for the Brazilians it's
gonna be a big turnaround there hits
that shot on suits amounts of one-on-one
Guardian versus taco it may just be it
was one of the most dramatic runs in
major history fallen had finally done it
more than ten years after his first
counter-strike tournament she had a
restored Brazil to a position of power
and glory in the world
it was indisputable that LG was the best
team in the world with fallen their
mastermind their leader can you sum up
to me just what this means to the
country of Brazil and your teammates
just to sum it up this is our dream
coming true and winning the biggest
tournament ever on Cisco means so much
to me personally and I'm sure it means a
lot to my teammates as well however
their success had not gone unnoticed and
with that came complications
the team became embroiled in a
controversial scandal surrounding their
sponsor and a potential switch to SK
gaming despite signing a letter of
intent to re-sign with luminosity gaming
the team had signed contracts with SK
gaming and just prior to MLG Columbus
the result was a lengthy public debate
and a legal battle over the future of
the team which was eventually settled on
June 24th 2016 when the team officially
transferred to SK their first tournament
under the SK banner was the ESL one
cologne major and just as they had at
MLG the Brazilians were gunning to take
it all our path to get here was very
difficult we had to go through a lot of
things so when we have a chance to win
another title we're gonna do everything
we can to win it so we're feeling
blessed to be here and we wanna get make
a great show and do our best they didn't
falter in their mission this time yes
the Scout II want the old for something
but the Fallen did it better
yep another terrific start here for SK
gaming he goes on five HP they have the
man advantage they still have all the
firepower and following they just can't
get anything going in underpass against
them he's always one step ahead
yeah another pick JDM has been spotted
by far as well
Nico is working his way towards
connected fur here's those steps so they
have all the information now let's make
gaming to make the play happen three
more kills even with this big of a lead
even with so much going their way they
still play it slow no one is rushing
anywhere no one's leaving anything to
charge ADM going down Pico going down
and now nitro low 1vs5 with a pistol
being flanked as well SK gaming what an
incredible team it's ops and nitro he
does get a shot and picks up an 8k but
there's no saving it he has to go and
fight and they're getting calls he has
the spray coming through he takes over
as well but he's talented 12 health and
now it's just all
[Music]
trying to walk through the smoke but
it's just not gonna happen SD gaming
second major championship in a row
take out your widows back-to-back major
titles left absolutely no doubts not
only was the roster one of the greatest
to ever play csgo fallen was one of the
greatest in-game leaders of the modern
era said the years trying to achieve
tournaments and I have the perfect guys
in my side heading into the back half of
2016
everyone expected fallen and SK to
continue to take home the hardware but
behind the scenes trouble was brewing
FNX always known as a bad boy was
causing tension in the team while eske's
results were nothing to sneeze at they
were not were fallen hoped they would be
he had fought so hard to reach the top
and anything less than first was a
disappointment now that he had tasted
victory FNX was removed from the team
and SK gaming played the E League major
in January of 2017 with Ricardo Fox
pajero as a stand-in while the team
sought out a new fifth member proving
just how good the team was even with a
stand-in SK gaming still finished top
four at the
eventually the up-and-coming star of
immortals how Phelps the vasconcelos was
selected to join the sk ranks the team
was once again focused driven and
determined to win titles the rest as
they say is history
or is that too before situation Phelps
on a flank now he can do a lot of work
he gets the last kill of Mo and SK
gaming your summer 2017 spring champions
he's found out by falling as well just
Nico and Kerrigan in the way of SK have
returned to form they dominated 2016
they won summit but they get to it
we bit without skill to quash this round
that's the first position though it's
known all three players will have their
folks trained on his location
fallen story is one of hard work paying
off dedication reaping rewards and
passion leading to victory
his nickname of the Godfather of
Brazilian CS is more than just a moniker
he's earned it games Academy which
started as just an online class all
those years ago and now boasts its own
content creators and has witnessed its
former roster now sponsored by immortals
finished second at the recent pgl major
a-fallin was once named the most
influential person in Brazilian eSports
and 2015 for his work building the
community teaching and spreading the
word of eSports will SE se ya would
utilize view that a society denotes
missiles can be falling asleep who is my
signal facility who says no say okay
don't cut down widow's value he's a
two-time major winner a respected leader
a fierce competitor in every aspect of
his life fallen has gone above and
beyond and something tells us he's just
getting started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]